[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute cette campagne
on fait le point sur vos préoccupations
au quotidien
reportage en france et décryptage de nos
journalistes
avec notre sondage et vos réactions bien
sûr sur nos réseaux sociaux les ouvriers
sont ils en danger c'est la question de
notre débat avec nos invités sur ce
plateau
fiodor rilov avocat des salariés de
l'usiné goodyear charles huet fondateur
de la carte française et xavier mathieu
ancien porte-parole cgt continental et
comédiens ainsi qu alexis poulain
journaliste et cofondateur du monde
moderne les licenciements et les
délocalisations dans l'industrie
française pèse lourd sur le climat
social
six ans après la fermeture de l'usiné
goodyear au nord d'amiens 832 salariés
sont retournés devant la justice mardi
dernier pour contester leur licenciement
économique
une centaine des usines ferment chaque
année en france depuis 10 ans maintenant
et 1 million
d'emplois ont été supprimés dans ce
secteur
écoutez vous dire surtout la gueule du
monde
eux en 2014 ils ont fait 2 5 milliards
d'euros de résultat net
c'était une profitabilité record enfin
c'était une explosion des dividendes et
cette année là ils viennent nous dire
que c'était pour motif économique ils
ont licencié 1143 personnes la raison en
est simple c'est qu'on a connus
provoquer une délocalisation vers la
pologne mais pâtissent fiscalité à payer
et c'est exactement les mêmes causes qui
ont produit les mêmes effets sur le site
qui est juste à côté de whirlpool là des
situations individuelles qui sont
catastrophiques des gens comparent
trouvé de boulot et que le peu qu'ils
retrouvent de boulot c'est toujours dans
la précarité donc goodyear a installé
durablement les gens dans la précarité
et aujourd'hui on veut venir dire voilà
c'est fini faut que ça cesse donc il ya
deux mondes qui se pose aujourd'hui il
ya celui de maquereaux et ya le lien
le mien c'est celui de l'ensemble des
salariés de cette région qu'ils n'en
peuvent plus d'être broyé au quotidien
parce que des actionnaires ont décidé de
faire tout et n'importe quoi sur cette
détresse suite au licenciement
économique
6 en étant bien sûr de goodyear qui sont
retournés devant les prud'hommes pour
obtenir gain de cause et obtenir justice
surtout vous dites c'est surtout un
combat pour la dignité humaine
oui enfin c'est un combat pour la
dignité mais c'est aussi un combat
actuel contre ce que macro et son
gouvernement ont mis en place depuis que
l'usiné a été fermée
vous savez qu'il ya eu plusieurs
réformes du code du travail
elle a été fermée ya six ans absolument
et que dans cet intervalle la voilà
entre 2014 et aujourd'hui hollande et
macron honte enlever du code du travail
quasiment tous les articles sur le
fondement desquels les salariés de
goodyear font le procès aux prud'hommes
c'est à dire que hollandais macron ont
pété le code du travail pardon chien
peut très bien pour que des groupes
comme goodyear puisse licencier
désormais sans entrave
parce que si un groupe fait aujourd'hui
ce que goodyear a fait en 2014
la possibilité d'attaquer ce groupe est
de dénoncer les licenciements comme
étant sans justification est quasi nul
voila et c'est absolument scandaleux
donc la bataille que mènent les salariés
qui ont été licenciés par goodyear
c'est une bataille qui est extrêmement
politique ils veulent que le juge disent
y'a pas de motif à nos licenciements et
en même temps ils veulent montrer
tall les multinationales sont encadrés
n'est pas supportable parce qu'en
réalité ces multinationales ne sont plus
encadrés du tout c'est liberté totale
faites ce que vous voulez casser l'outil
industriel licencier des gens à tout va
il ya plus limité au nom de la
compétitivité c'est ce que c'est ce que
met en avant en tout cas l usine
goodyear manque de compétitivité
attendait certains disent non c'est pas
vrai il y avait des bénéfices donc ça
sur la même non mais attendez là il n'ya
pas comment dire une sorte de
problématiques que mystérieuse il suffit
de regarder les comptes de la société
et lorsque les salariés ont été
licenciés les comptes du groupe goodyear
affichait 2,5 milliards de dollars de
profits nets profit net c'est à dire que
les impôts avait été payée
tout a été réglé et ses 2,5 milliards
était dans la poche des actionnaires
bon donc il n'y a pas de débat autour de
cette question des performances de
goodyear non la vraie question qui est
sur la table c'est est ce que il faut
considérer qu'une société ou un groupe
qui fait des profits absolument
gigantesque doit être empêchée de
licencier ou est ce que il faut dire à
ce type de multinationales si vous
faites beaucoup de profits et bien
merveilleux continuer à en faire
davantage
même si cela doit passer par des
licenciements par la destruction de
l'industrie par le fait de sinistrés des
bassins d'emploi par l'écrasement des
vies humaines
on va on a parlé des conséquences
évidemment sur les territoires également
un xavier mathieu vous vous avez vécu
cette situation avait été licenciés de
l'usiné continental de clairoix dans
l'oise en 2009
comment est ce qu'on vit ces situations
mais c'est terrible mais j'ai attendu 11
ans pour toucher mes indemnités
définitive j'étais poursuivi en justice
donc et ce qui est terrible c'est que
aujourd'hui les conti encore plus de la
moitié des mecs qui sont à la rue
compass travail et en ayant eu des
indemnités assez colossal à l'époque on
a réussi à se battre on a réussi à avoir
tous que avec les lois mac ronde les
gens ne pourront plus avoir ce qui veut
dire c'est que les gens aujourd'hui onze
ans après il y en a la moitié dans la
merde
et encore on a réussi à se battre et à
obtenir des indemnités qui ont fait que
les gens le temps a duré était un peu
moins dure des gens à l'avenir là ils
vont se faire virer et en plus avec rien
c'est à dire que les plafonds seront
fixés les gens s'ouvrent et les usines
pourront fermer tout en sachant combien
ça leur coûtera c'est-à-dire qu'ils
pourront même faire comme avec nous ils
ont dit qu'il fallait faire des efforts
on a baissé nos salaires on a baissé nos
primes
c'est à dire que pendant deux ans le
patron il a fait des économies avec avec
cet argent là il l'a mis de côté avec
cet argent il a payé les licenciements
c'est à dire c'est c'est eh oui mais en
fait on se rend compte que goodyear
comme les autres en fait plus les usines
sont riches plus c'est facile pour eux
licenciés
donc voilà c'est à dire que plus les
ouvriers sont font du profit plus les
usines gagne d'argent et plus c'est
facile de licencier et qu'ils ont du
pognon continental ça leur a coûté le
prix d'une usine neuve
la fermeture de l'usiné ça leur coûtait
300 millions d'euros c'est le prix de l'
usine continental 9 imaginez ils ont
fait 7 milliards de bénéfices depuis
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dans le foot alexis
poulain est ce que l'état aide justement
est ce que ces entreprises ne ferme pas
est ce que la l'action d'état en matière
de deux supports en tout cas de ces
industries est suffisante donc vous sûr
que non enfin vous avez à la fois l'état
qui aide les entreprises à aller à saint
à s'implanter alors on fait beaucoup de
cadeaux
cadets fiscal il faut être compétitif
dans l'attrait de l'investisseur
étranger donc on fait tout pour les
faire venir eux-mêmes sur sûre quand ce
n'est pas l'industrie les traders on
veut les faire venir et surtout qui paye
moins d'impôts que les autres parce que
ils ont beaucoup d'argent à cette
fameuse théorie de l'attractivité
donc on leur fait des ponts en or et
quelques années après quand les usines
ferment les politiques s'agitent devant
les caméras font des promesses font
semblant en fait de dire qu'on va faire
quelque chose n'existe pas ce rien ils
sont tout à fait déposséder à partir du
moment où vous tenez l'emploi par
l'investissement c'est extrêmement
volatile
une usine une entreprise une
multinationale elle a pas de pays
elle va aller en fonction de nouvelles
cadeau donc elle va arriver évidemment
mais d'abord aussi il ya le côté
incitations fiscales et puis on veut
bien se faire voir et puis c'est un bon
marché la france quand vous êtes
blackrock bon bah c'est bien c'est un
nouveau marché qui va s'ouvrir avec les
retraites par exemple
donc on fait tout pour plaire en disant
que c'est très bien donc on vous offre
des emplois et là le politique est
content il met sur son petit tableau on
va regarder on nous
re mi-temps d'emplois que fait macron
depuis qu'il est lui bien en janvier
avant davos il invite tous les grands
investisseurs internationaux il dit ils
m'ont promis des milliards ils m'ont
promis plein d'emplois
oui on attend toujours les emplois
promis en 2019 pour 2020 mais là en 2020
a refait des promesses et ça dans
quelques années on n'aura pas plus
d'emplois et puis le moment où il une
ferme on ne peut plus rien faire
donc il faut pas croire que parce que
les investisseurs sont attirés à un
moment par un pays ils vont y rester ils
vont surtout faire de l'emploi pérenne
c'est certainement pas ça alors comment
faire de l'emploi pérenne en france
charles huet vous diriger une entreprise
vous même comment est ce que est ce que
c'est le coût de la main d'oeuvre qui
fait que l'industrie est plus ou moins
sinistré aujourd'hui en france il ya
différents sujets sur la compétitivité
après c'est surtout d'avoir des d'avoir
une usine qui tourne qui a des lignes de
production aux plaines qui vend ses
produits qui vend ses produits à des
consommateurs parce qu'on a tous un rôle
on n'est pas que spectateur de tout ça à
des consommateurs qui font savoir que
ils arrêteront de consommer ces produits
des pneus ou des who des sèche-linge ou
d'autres produits
s'ils arrêtent d'être fabriqués dans la
région et c'est le sens voilà de la
carte française que j'ai lancée du made
in france c'est c'est les syndicalistes
et les acteurs économiques et sociaux
s'appuie sur les consommateurs et
agissent concrètement avec avec leur
carte bleue au quotidien à l'intérieur
de la france là on reste sur le marché
interne sur marché intérieur en soit les
français à acheter français pour pousser
ces entreprises à maintenir les emplois
les emplois localement parce que voilà
et demain dire que par le pool ayant
délocalisé en pologne j'arrête d'acheter
du groupe poule c'est une des solutions
essayer de garder ces industries en
france bat de fait cesser à la fin à la
fin de la journée en dernier ressort
c'est sur le consommateur qui qui dirige
ses actionnaires s'ils veulent vendre
s'ils veulent faire des profits il faut
bien que leurs produits soient vendus
ici les consommateurs arrêtent d'acheter
les produits d'actionnaires ou direction
qui considère comme voyou pas vertueuse
est bien égale inverse
ils soutiennent concrètement mais faut
il ne faut pas seulement le dire faut le
faire au quotidien le fruit du travail
de ses usines
forcément ça va aller dans le bon sens
et dans le sens du maintien de ces
villes alors on va faire un petit tour
dans la région centre val de loire c'est
la moins attractive de france est celle
qui a le plus faible taux de gauche par
habitant en france un chômage qui a
augmenté pour les plus de 50 ans et une
perte d'activité qui concerne plutôt les
femmes on va le voir un dernier
trimestre 2010 9 avec une nette
augmentation des arrivées pour
licenciement économique c + 8 % des
inscrits voyez ce reportage de nadège
abderrazak et lucas tueur ne m'appelez
plus jamais arjowiggins est ma dernière
volonté
ah bah oui là oui parce que c'est
c'est ce qu'on a vécu ce qu'ont vécu and
broad 1 et 5 169 autres salariés c'est
la fermeture d'arjowiggins une usine de
papier
implanté depuis près de deux siècles à
bessé sur braye village de 2200
habitants pour de nombreux salariés les
dirigeants n'ont rien fait pour éviter
le naufrage pire il l'aurait provoqué
peut-être qu'on se trompe mais on est
persuadé que c'était volontaire la fin
de cette usine
elle n'a pas pour nous aller c'est pas
qu'elle ait pas justifié c'est vrai que
le marché de dupes à pied était en
déclin c'est vrai mais là il ya eu des
choses qu'on n'explique pas et qu'on ne
nous explique pas et on se dit que c'est
c'est vraiment la volonté de quelqu'un à
55 ans et après 28 ans de bons et loyaux
services and bredin s'interroge sur son
avenir professionnel
optimiste elle reste toutefois réaliste
sur ses chances de retrouver un emploi
faudra que je trouve n'importe quelle
solution pour pour travailler un minimum
parce que alors peut-être à mi temps
peut-être je sais pas 2007 pour moi
c'est pas possible d'imaginer ne pas
retrouver de travail
quand on est senior et femmes c'est
peut-être encore plus compliqué parce
que il ya des postes pour les hommes qui
ont retrouvé en tant que menuisier en
tant que soudeur et ce à une femme
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué pourquoi
l'état n'est-il pas intervenu c'est
l'une des questions qui hantent and
broad 1 pour elle les ex-salariés ont
été abandonnés par les pouvoirs publics
quand on a les anciennetés que la grande
majorité des salariés avaient oui on est
on est écoeuré on est écoeuré on est
dégoûtés par le système ce n'est pas
pensable que l'état ne fasse rien pour
on a vu des politiques on avait beaucoup
de politiques mais il n'y a rien eu de
fait vraiment mais on se demande
pourquoi pourquoi il n'y a rien de fait
pour soutenir
est ce que l'état aurait pu faire
quelque chose nous nous pensons que oui
parce qu'il a payé
des millions des millions pour fermer
l'usiné
les licenciements ont coûté énormément
d'argent il aurait mieux fallu donner
les millions et
on préfère partir lusine quoi fiodor
rilov on le voit le désarroi de ces
personnes acquises ne savais même pas si
elles vont retrouver un emploi c'est pas
le cas de tout le monde
comment comment est-ce que les ces
personnes font justement pour essayer de
se former un nouvel emploi retrouver une
vie normale
retrouver un travail ça vous l'avez vécu
avec les personnes que vous défendez
comment elles font comment ils font ce
qu'elles sont et ds des bruits par m
c'est absolument scandaleux ce qui se
passe lorsque les gens ont été licenciés
dans ces conditions il n'ya aucune
structure sérieuse
il ya évidemment plein d'entreprises
prestataires de services qui viennent
s'enrichir
parce que des collectivités parce que
l'état met de l'argent à disposition
mais tout ça est avalée par des
structures qui s'enrichissent de manière
absolument insupportable pendant que les
salariés cherchent du boulot par e mail
xavier peut en témoigner bien mieux que
moi c'est absolument délirant mais je
voudrais quand même réagir par rapport à
ce qu'a dit cette dame là tous les
salariés de ce pays
lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à une
restructuration surtout lorsqu'elle est
mise en oeuvre par une multinationale
extrêmement riches se disent l'état doit
intervenir
oui voilà c'est ce qu'on nous se tourne
assez spontanément mais n'a rien d'un
terreau vers l'état comme étant un
interlocuteur crédible qui a des
prérogatives qui a des pouvoirs et qui a
priori apparaît comme du côté des
citoyens qui subissent la tacc
injustifiée de ces multinationales comme
ça que c'est perçu une attaque d'une
multinationale souvent d'ailleurs voilà
dont on a eu du mal à identifier la
nation dont certaines se trouvaient sont
subventionnées par l'argent public un
donc et moi mon expérience rien et moi
ce que je voudrais c'est témoigner de ce
que je vois tous les jours ce que je
vois tous les jours c'est que l'état
dans ce pays est le meilleur prestataire
de services ont pour le compte de ces
multinationales
c'est que derrière le discours qui
consiste à expliquer qu'on va tout
mettre en oeuvre qu'on va essayer de les
aider
vous avez en france une machine macro
nien qui idéologiquement c'est des
ayatollahs de l'ultra libe
l'isthme il pense que la destruction
d'une usine c'est bien il pense que
c'est ça qui va générer de l'énergie
ils sont complètement c'est à dire que
leur position c'est même pas une
position conservatrice etc ils sont des
militants de la destruction industriel
moi c'est ce que j'ai sous les yeux et
vous avez peut-être le sentiment que je
caricature je peux vous garantir que
avant d'arriver à cette conclusion qui
moi même temps a ajouté que j'étais
attendu mon passé les sauver saison
enfin c'est certain ça mais ça c'est le
saas et le merveilleux discours
ça c'est la vitrine ce que vous voyez
derrière lorsque les emplois sont
véritablement en péril ou lorsque par
exemple un certain nombre d'entreprises
viennent ici pour s'accaparer des bijoux
de l'industrie française
general electric ce samedi c'était hier
donc j'étais avec les salariés de
général elektriks à belfort bon et je
connaissais un peu la situation
ceux qui m'ont raconté sur la manière
dont macron déjà à l'époque étaient
intervenus pour essayer d'endormir tout
le monde alors que d'endormir tout le
monde pour que les gens acceptent sur
place que cette industrie soit
transférée à une multinationale
américaine
alors qu'on savait on savait dès le
départ que son intention était de
démanteler l'essentiel des unités
industrielles de alstom en france de les
délocaliser et surtout de ne pas remplir
les promesses qui avaient été faites en
matière d'emploi je vous rappelle que
3000 emplois devaient être créés c'est
écrit noir sur blanc s'est même signé il
faut spar macron ça n'a jamais été
réalisé par un emploi a été créé au
contraire on en détruit des milliers
toussaint est en réalité accompagner
encourager par l'appareil d'état macro
n'y en a pas le problème c'est qu'on a
on arrive toujours enfin en fin de
course quand l' usine ferme
on n'est pas on n'a pas les armes en
fait pour c'est médiatisé et bien sûr
mais met par exemple en ce moment vous
avez paris europlace la place financière
de paris qui réfléchit à un système pour
se protéger des fonds agressif en disant
qu'il faudrait éviter que des
investisseurs justement rentrer au
capital deviennent majoritaires et puis
ensuite demande a craché plus de profits
pour liquider les boîtes alors ça ça
fait des bardes mais si on commence à
faire des lois pour se protéger on va
être moins attractif on revient ce
problème de l'attractivité andorre
l'investisseur va pas venir vous savez
c'est compliqué donc c'est toujours le
politique qui fait la loi
or le politique il est lâche il ne fait
pas les bonnes lois
pire encore parfois il est juste
lobbyistes pour l'industrie pour la
multinationale qui va le payer derrière
donc il est il et il est même complice
c'est ce que je disais c'est parce que
par exemple on voir le problème dès
qu'il y des caisses de chômage les
retraites par les retraites aujourd'hui
la guerre sur les retraites aujourd'hui
c'est pas l'histoire des heures et des
jours travaillés donnons d'année la
vérité c'est que les quêtes là sont
pillées depuis des années le cic hausse
et 40 milliards et 40 milliards qui
devait embaucher
il devait embaucher soi-disant il avait
son petit badge un mode d'emploi un
million d'emplois ils n'ont pas embauché
une personne ce qui est encore plus
cynique dans l'histoire c'est que vous
vous rendez compte que non seulement ils
n'ont pas embauché mais la plupart des
entreprises se sont servis de cet argent
pour licencier ça veut dire que cet
argent n'a pas servi à embaucher des
gens il a servi à licencier et à dire
que le dividende bien sûr sur le peuple
le peuple le peuple français
les français par leurs impôts ont payé
ont contribué au licenciement de toutes
les usines actuelles qui qui part dans
tous ces gouvernements on vous dit
le chômage il faut aller pointer pour
info il faut justifier ce alors que j'ai
rien à justifier c'est ce que c'est ce
que je paye tous les mois dans mon
salaire et le jour où chômage c'est à
moi c'est pas au gouvernement
peu importe on doit toujours justifier
d'un emploi ou d'une période de chômage
ou ou par exemple et 42 milliards qui
ont été versés quelle entreprise a eu à
justifier une embauche ou pas comment on
peut donner autant de pognon
assez assez entreprises ils n'embauchent
pas une seule personne et comment on
peut ne pas réclamer cet argent au
minimum quand il ferme les boîtes parce
qu'ils ne peuvent même pas le faire chez
red bull ils ont touché du pognon ils
ont pas rendu l'argent c'est terrible
les caisses de la
la problématique des retraites
aujourd'hui comme le chômage comme le
reste ce n'est pas qu'elles sont vides
parce qu'il n'ya plus il ya trop de
travaux gens qui travaillent par rapport
au chômage elles sont vides parce que
c'est c'est on se polit le salaire des
souris parce que les réductions de taxes
de machin c'est pas vrai quand l'état
fait un cadeau des charges patronales
des appels des charges patronales ce
sont des cotisations sociales c'est mon
salaire quand quand eux quand il fait
une économie de 1000 euros sur le sur
mon salaire demain c'est mon salaire
c'est l'argent qui doit aller dans les
caisses sociales ce sont des salaires
différés qui font que c'est mince et
c'est ma retraite que je que je paye
l'état fait cadeau de ma retraite aux
patrons et après quelques années plus
tard il vient vous dire les caisses sont
vite votre avis tu es trois ans de plus
ça veut dire que dans l'hérault ma
retraite et sur le débat des retraites
on va se dérouler c'est l'exemple et la
cotisation sociale des cadeaux on en
train de parler de 2 milliards qui ont
été données par les entrefaits reparler
pas par lui par l'état aux patrons on
l'aurait utilisée pour fabriquer des
emplois il y aurait des millions
d'emplois aujourd'hui clair il faut
arrêter de faire semblant de croire que
pour mac rond et tous ceux qui poussent
dans la même direction que lui
c'est anormal c'est pas anormal heureux
pour eux c'est exactement le résultat
recherché même si évidemment pour
expliquer l'ensemble de ces dispositifs
ils disent que c'est favorable à la
création d'emplois ils sont fous tu te
rends compte que les actionnaires
s'enrichissent grâce à l'argent du lundi
doivent lancer son centre ils sont pour
une résolution avec l'embauché lui a
donné vie des dizaines d'années
aujourd'hui une nouvelle génération de
dire on va donner en 2018 il y a eu
un regain en tout cas l'érosion de
l'industrie française s'est arrêtée en
2018 suite au au cic où vous en parliez
peut-être aux mesures incitatives en
tout cas pour essayer de d'encourager
ses cette industrie charles juliet
quand on est à la tête d'une entreprise
il faut aussi être compétitif sans pour
rester ouverts vous l'avez d'écouteurs
ça veut dire quoi un coût du travail qui
devraient être moindres c'est toutes ces
mesures en fait qu'ils sont attendues au
niveau des entre 6 et pas forcément sur
le coût du travail il faut regarder
toutes les choses comparables
mais il ya le sujet des dû effectivement
du contexte réglementaire et fiscale via
les taxes de production en particulier
en france qui sont qui interroge parce
que c'est tout les tous les impôts
qu'une entreprise va payer avant de
générer le premier centime de chiffre
d'affaires ce qui est est ce qu'il ya un
vide quand même à relativiser quand même
à questionner ce sujet de la
compétitivité c'est que parce qu'on
n'est pas très compétitifs
non mais un pays bas un pays comme la
suisse par exemple catherine gras on
voit le couple travaille en france et 38
euros et 42 pour l'allemagne et
l'allemagne a deux fois plus strict des
actionnaires après mon petit en france
le taux de production là où il est
meilleur
donc si l'on en croit le cher et
concours aux grecs ont produit 10 ou 20%
de plus le suit 3 % de plus de salaire
on va vous savez les patrons ils ont
choisi le sujet c'est pas le coût du
travail c'est le reste du contexte
fiscal fiscales et réglementaires en
suisse
en suisse il ya quatre fois plus
d'emplois industriels qu'on france par
tête de puits de 40 % de l'emploi
salarié suisse et industriels la suisse
c'est pas un c'est pas un pays dirigiste
c'est pas un pays enfin c'est un pays
plutôt libérale qui a un contexte
libéral et fiscales et réglementaires
qui est attractif et du coup ça génère
dans ce cas de figure de l'emploi
industriel parce que parce qu'on n'en
tire pas les investisseurs et
l'investissement foncier important de
toute usine avec des taxes de production
par exemple je pense pas du tout que le
sujet sur le coût du travail et les
salariés suisses sont beaucoup plus haut
que les salaires tout à fait tout à fait
mais parce que c'est la conséquence
d'une compétitivité de deux fleurons
industriels et un moment donné il faut
quand même se questionner sur notre
niveau de chômage notre niveau des gens
discrets vision on est la france en
qualité de la production aussi peut-être
sûrement mais enfin la qualité elle
vient pas de nulle part quand vous me
non mais quand les usines non non non
plus l'argent parce qu'on l'a ils l'ont
payé en taxes de production pour
investir dans l'outil de
de production ils peuvent pas aider
leurs salariés à adé à démultiplier leur
productivité leur qualité donc non il
faut se il faut se l'exemple suisse et
est intéressant il faut se rendre compte
qu aujourd'hui on est la france et plus
d industrialiser que la grande bretagne
donc on a un pays qui enfin on est on
doit quand même se comparer à ceux qui
sont comparables on a des voisins qui
ont des contextes de deux niveaux une
vie à peu près ça près similaires et on
fait donc on doit se poser et puis on va
écouter bruno le maire il ne s'est
exprimé
justement quand il a parlé de son pacte
productif pour le plein emploi c'était
en octobre dernier
écoutez nous avons besoin d'une
stratégie collective pour la nation un
pacte productif permettant d'atteindre
le plein emploi en 2025
je ne vois pas pourquoi la part de la
production industrielle est passé de 17
% à 12 % de la richesse nationale en
france quand elle s'est maintenue à 23 %
en allemagne à 18 % en italie il ya 14 %
en espagne dont gala la part de
l'industrie qui a considérablement
baissé en france pourquoi alors que nos
voisins européens c'est pas le cas
alexis poulain non mais alors bouleversé
la présence à le béotien vous savez ça
le pacte productif c'est pareil c'est
comme lépine sur un million d'emplois ça
va finir dans un carton on n'entendra
plus parler
il y a c'est à dire que oui avec
quelques milliards pour les amis au
passage ça c'est la façon dont ça
fonctionne il n'y a pas de plan en fait
pour l'industrie en france il n'y en a
jamais eu à vrai dire il ya un plan par
contre c'est pour effacer et enlever le
monde ouvrier des radars parce que
derrière
depuis toujours le monde ouvrier celle
d'angers en politique c'est le monde
syndical c'est le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec les règles des riches et
ça se voit et c'est devenu pourquoi
aujourd'hui il ya cette ce désamour
aussi de l'industrie c'est que pendant
des années on dit que ce n'était pas une
filière s'étaient pas un emploi c'était
une voie de garage
ouais vous vous étiez mauvais à l'école
et ben se faisait une formation s'était
pas quelque chose qui était une carrière
en allemagne s'est encore une carrière
c'est une façon d'entrer dans le monde
du travail et c'est même les patrons
allemands la différence peut-être que
les industries étrangères marche mieux
parce que le patron commence sur la
chaîne de montage
il sait de quoi il parle nous en france
on a des énarques après ils arrivent ils
savaient pas du tout goût et à la presse
par l'état français
voilà mes empreintes sont cryptées
envoyées vers l'industrie dans ce pays
exactement ça c'est absolument
incroyable c'est qu'aujourd'hui où se
tourner vers l'angleterre où on se
tourne vers les états unis pour y
trouver quelques exemples de
l'intervention de l'état en faveur de
ces pays sont dirigés
c'est culturel c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est que bruno le maire en ajoutant
c'est quand il fait une visite avec
carlos ghosn déguisés en ouvriers il ne
connaît rien de lusine on va en reparler
rester avec nous on continue ce débat
sur l'état de l'industrie en france la
galère des ouvriers qui ont subi des des
plans sociaux pourquoi la france a du
mal à être compétitives dans ce secteur
on en parle dans quelques minutes
[Musique]
il faut bien comprendre que les chante
schiste pétroliers américains donc
quelques temps vont s'arrêter de
produire si vous voulez toutes les
données pétrolières sont confidentielles
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'à terme
avec le pétrole de schiste les
américains soient énergétiquement
indépendant ben non ils sont en train de
frôler indépendance mais pour le pour le
gaz il y semant mais pour le pétrole
non c'est puis là le puits de gist sont
des puits qui donne le maximum
les premiers mois après c'est une chute
continuelle
si le pétrole de schiste des cent cette
année suffisamment pour que s'asseoir
notable en moins de vendre 30 ne sera
pareil
[Musique]
ou est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
radicalisation dans les sports que le
terme radicalisation c'est un peu un mot
valise et ont même beaucoup de choses
qui ne reflète pas la réalité l'entente
de la radicalisation islamiste dans le
sport c'est tout ce processus qui peut
conduire quelqu'un à se mettre en marge
totale de la société parfois même
basculer vers l'action violente en 2016
- sportif considéré que ce n'était pas
son affaire et qu'il n'avait pas à être
en une sorte de délateurs des pouvoirs
plus parce que le sujet c'est
qu'aujourd'hui toute une série de
phénomènes nous échappe
ce sont ces associations qui se créent
ou bien des structures qui se créent en
dehors du mouvement organisé certains
ont dit le sport amateur c'est le sait
le premier lieu vecteur de
radicalisation c'est faux c'est la
prison dans les clubs
il peut y avoir des cas de prosélytisme
mais pas contre les radicaliser ne vont
plus à la mosquée ne sont plus à l'école
ne sont plus dans les clubs retirer vos
de la tête le sport à 6 à 10
[Musique]
pollitt mag la suite avec fiodor rilov
avocat des salariés de l'usiné goodyear
charles huet fondateur de la carte
française xavier mathieu ancien
porte-parole cgt continental et comédien
aujourd'hui et alexis poulain
journaliste co fondateur du monde
moderne
la france connaît depuis des années
maintenant des fermetures d'usinés
d'être sociaux à répétition est
particulièrement touché le secteur
automobile mais la france a aussi des
fleurons comme l'aéronautique ou le
secteur du luxe est à des lieues des
usines en france avec notre journaliste
guy marosi l'industrie en france cela
représente 9,6 pour cent des emplois
mais c'est aussi un secteur économique
en chute depuis des décennies avec des
licenciements économiques qui défrayent
régulièrement la chronique
au gré des fermetures d'usinés on peut
donner l'exemple de l'usiné du
constructeur automobile ford situé à
blanquefort au nord de bordeaux qui a
fermé ses portes le 1er octobre dernier
849 employés licenciés dont philippe
poutou candidat malheureux du nouveau
parti anticapitaliste aux
présidentielles on peut aussi citer
whirpool à amiens dont 138 salariés ont
été licenciés en août dernier malgré un
rachat en 2018 il y à aussi general
electric qui supprimera 485 postes sur
son site de belfort d'ici à fin 2020 ou
encore le site de tupperware près de
tours qui a licencié 220 salariés en
février 2018 il y a eu aussi
arcelormittal à florange et gandrange
goodyear encore à amiens et il ne s'agit
là que de quelques plans sociaux parmi
les plus récents en réalité la liste est
beaucoup beaucoup plus longue en 2016
cent soixante trois mille personnes se
sont inscrites sur les listes de pôle
emploi après un licenciement économique
elle était 144000 en 2017 un chiffre en
baisse donc mais qui doit être mis en
perspective avec le nombre de ruptures
conventionnelles qui lui a véritablement
explosé
quatre cent trente huit mille en 2018
alors pourquoi les plans sociaux dans
l'industrie attire-t-il autant
l'attention médiatique est bien parce
qu'ils sont particulièrement
dévastateurs les salariés de ce secteur
ont beaucoup de difficultés à retrouver
un emploi et sont souvent contraints de
choisir entre
déménager avec les complications que
cela implique ou faire une croix sur
leurs compétences et leur expérience en
changeant de métier sans compter que
travailleurs licenciés rime souvent avec
ville sinistrée
et puis les fermetures revêtent souvent
un enjeu électoral les leaders
politiques se pressent régulièrement au
chevet des usines en difficulté sont
d'ailleurs pouvoir faire grand chose à
part et d un peu un repreneur éventuel
car les entreprises sondées propriété
privée détenue par des actionnaires qui
le sont tout autant et l'union
européenne fixe des règles très strictes
sur la libre concurrence qui limite et
c'est peu dire
toute action étatique l'état ne peut pas
tout avait déploré le premier ministre
socialiste lionel jospin en 99
une vérité toujours cliente même vingt
ans plus tard jeux d'argent c'est vrai
que l'état ne paie pas intervenir en
tout cas parfois pour sauver pour ça
parce qu'on aura le lien avec ce qui va
se passer si tout d'un coup l'état
français décide de faire usage de toutes
ses prérogatives pour empêcher la
fermeture d'une usine
ils vont nous envoyer quoi bruxelles là
il va se passer quoi mais les amendes
qu'on citait des anglais bon maintenant
ils sont sortis de l'europe
il ya peut-être un lien d'ailleurs où
les allemands médéa nurullah les
allemands ils interviennent
il intervient dès lors ce que l'union
européenne cherche à empêcher l'état
allemand de protéger son industrie que
vous garantir qu'il ya une réponse de la
part des autres alors que souvent les
autorités locales mais elle aussi vous
avez juncker qui était président de la
commission qui vaut aux états unis c'est
d'abord pour négocier pour l'industrie
automobile est logiquement mais parce
quelqu'un sur ce que vous avez en france
depuis presque un quart de siècle une
position étatique idéologique qui est
favorable à la libéralisation à tout
crin et surtout à ce que l'état se
désengage de tous les secteurs pour
laisser libre cours à l'appétit des
multinationales ya vraiment une position
idéologique que je vois je la vois tous
les jours et qui doit a dénoncé et
combattu et l'état a des moyens et
l'union européenne peut évidemment être
mise en recul lorsque l'état décide
c'est le faire usage de ses pouvoirs
c'est pas tant l'union européenne qui
est là et qui
kim et dirais que ce qu'il ya dans la
tête des gens qui sont à la fois
bruxelles et au gouvernement français
on a affaire à quelqu'un quand même
emmanuel macron qui pense la france
comme une entreprise en mode start up
injecter d'argent et il ya derrière
l'idée d'une et au management public une
idéologie qui fait que l'état serait
inefficace qui coûterait trop cher qui
sert à rien et qu'on doit faire dans le
public ce que fait le privé est derrière
vous avez une guerre mais sémantique et
qui datent pas d'aujourd'hui
vous avez affaire à des directions des
ressources humaines qui sont d'ailleurs
nombreux gouvernements la ressource
humaine c'est quoi ces cantons il humain
quand on en fait une commodité comme une
autre matière première c'est l'humain et
là on n'a plus rien à voir avec un
ouvrier avec quelqu'un qui est qualifié
qu'à une histoire qu'à une vie certes on
s'en fout c'est un chiffre c'est une
ressource
ça ça fait longtemps ça fait longtemps
que ça existe mais là on est à on
atteint vraiment un niveau extrêmement
dangereux et pourquoi on en arrive là
c'est que vous avez vu ce reportage
cette dame qu'à 55 ans qui sait très
bien qu'elle va pas retrouvé d'emploi
qui a passé sa vie dans cette usine pour
s'en fout de sa gueule
elle est virée parce que c'est la
ressource humaine et derrière en plus on
atomisent les gens c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous en avez des ouvriers
vous en avez beaucoup mais ils sont plus
dans les industries ils sont sur des
vélos pour les plateformes
internationales américaines parce qu'ils
vendent quoi ils vendent leur corps on
en est là on en train de retourner à un
19e ou ou alors qu'on avait fait avec
les luttes syndicales avec les buts on
avait réussi à avoir un droit du travail
tout ça est en train d'être détricoter à
la vitesse de l'éclair ces scandaleuses
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
incroyable et vous n'avez plus justement
parce qu'on a perdu les ouvriers dans la
sémantique de représentants ouvriers de
culture ouvrière de force syndical
regarder les syndicats ils sont pas en
ordre de bataille
et tout ça député ouvriers de députés
voudraient pas à la télé vous ne les
voyez pas la culture ouvrière ce moment
qu'ils étaient forts qui était un moment
un art show syndicalistes qui est
parquée pas rien qui fait après tout
tout ce qu'on sait des luttes de la
libération etc
il a ici s'est évaporé que tu m'écoutes
pascal règles sociales en mairie alors
justement il ya eu les cdc critiquer ses
errements politiques
une des pistes explorées par le
gouvernement justement pour certainement
pas remettre retourner en tout cas cette
image de l'industrie redonner de
l'attractivité pour les jeunes étudiants
aujourd'hui dans ces secteurs jeu
comment comment ce faire
c'est des choix politiques sinon ils ont
fait ça décide de donner 40 milliards
des entreprises qui ne vont pas
embaucher une personne tout temps dans
le même temps en liquidant les services
les services publics en licenciant les
fonctionnaires le choix décide de mettre
de l'argent dans du non-emploi en
licenciant des gens - cegid en même
temps c'est 120 da temps ci dans les
yeux bien sûr des personnes spécialisées
voilà je sais que ma question maintenant
effectivement le les métiers de
l'industrie ont été ont été largement
dénigrer pendant des années on a cru que
le d entreprise sans usine c'était
l'avenir de l'occident on s'aperçoit que
social ou à outrance ouais alors
aujourd'hui la lamal à l'automatisation
et la robotisation vont plutôt dans le
sens de la colocalisation de l'industrie
vous poser la question pourquoi on
l'état ne peut pas faire dans la
question c'est pourquoi en dehors pour
l'article c'est ça mais pourquoi on doit
donc on doit attendre après l'été un peu
pourquoi attendre attendre que l'état
d'avoir une idée en tête le quotidien de
manière sémantique c'est très bien moi
je le quotidien dans mes achats réalisés
ce qui fait que moi derrière je sais pas
où sont fabriqués vos jeans et votre
costume mais moi du coup d ar moor
derrière moi sommes ensuite je sais qu'à
une couturière à roubaix dermont jim je
sais qu'il ya des cadets qui a des gars
à nancy derrière mais messi ni coeur je
sais qu'il ya une usine la dernière dans
les vosges de chaussures à un moment
donné ça dépend aussi de nous moi
j'entends beaucoup de deux velléitaire
de bavards un moment donné chaque entre
deux élections présidentielles on va 150
euros au supermarché on à noël pour ont
fait des cadeaux à tout le monde
on a notre rôle aussi sont là droit de
critiquer on va leur poser ton posé mais
selon challenges lanta jamais espèce de
gestion permanente c'est comme
l'environnement les citoyens dans une
poubelle fermée mais faire croire non
plus que ça va changer quoi que ce soit
mais bien sûr quasi mais le
médecin-commandant une age origins et
moi je m'achète des produits français
avec un smic à me lever à 1200 euros
ces produits là je ne concevais je ne
consomme que français depuis tanger dame
était jamais se toucher plus que le
salaire médian français de chercher il
ya la moitié du concert c'est 2016 ça
veut dire qu'à la moitié des français
qui peuvent se le permettre
c'est un son une route plus est le 1 le
lave et le jury t et le sujet c'est pas
de l'imposer à une mère célibataire
smeeckaert et aux contraintes d'avoir en
tête effectivement que son sort sa
saison parité sont une employabilité et
sa tristesse quand l'usiné ferme au
moment de mes achats
cette empathie et cette colère elle doit
pas être que vis-à-vis de 2,2 d'autrui
d'aller chercher une autre
responsabilité on a aussi tous c'est pas
la seule c'est pas là c'est pas l'alpha
et l'oméga
on a tous aussi notre petite part de
responsabilité les cee chaque année à la
tête desquels figure siègent des élus
syndicaux distribuer un milliard et demi
d'euros de cartes cadeaux qui
aujourd'hui vont être dépensés en
amazone h&m chaque année des élus
syndicaux ont via ses activités
culturelles se relancèrent industriels
on peut le faire on peut le faire chacun
d'entre nous et déjà c'est un moyen de
rendre l'action plus concret l'ouvrier
effectivement qu'on oublie qu'elle est
loin des yeux loin du coeur de la france
périphérie du gilet jaune se dire moi
j'achète le fruit de son travail de sa
dignité
et ça lui donne un salaire et sa
pérennise la ville et demi plus tard
aussi on est un pays ça manger français
s'habiller français acheter français
penser penser aux usines et à tous les
impacts parce que c'est fabriqué et
français 2
cela tu le sais pas d'où il vient des
mois tirent aussi convenu qu elle aussi
à la française mais voilà ça nous
empêche pas ça empêche pas le coton
d'être des exploités l'afrique pour
faire le coton du tee shirt c'est ça qui
m'intéresse ryanair du sien il ya du
bien du linge on dirait qu est ce que ça
garantit toute la chaîne de production
et français non non rien aucun produit
n'est 100% français et c'est pas une
inspiration soit le but c'est entre cinq
produits pour ce dont j'ai besoin
eh bien il ya une des marques qui génère
plus d'emplois directs industriel local
que les autres eh ben je privilégie
celle ci voit là et je hais je le fais
bruyamment
parce qu'aujourd'hui je fais un média en
tant que consommateur je peux promouvoir
vous dénigrez et jeu et je fais savoir
que sa main à sa ma porte et que si
demain le sèche-linge leur poule et les
plus fabrique à amiens eh ben je gérais
déjà chaîne de légères de lâcher points
alors écoutez justement emmanuel macron
qu'il veut faire la promotion du
fabricant cette réunion à l'elysée en
janvier dernier manuel ma croix
rassembler les entrepreneurs justement
pour une grande exposition du made in
france regardez écoutez le on peut pas
demander de fabriquer en france si
derrière on n'a pas un coût du capital
qui est compétitif on s'est arrangé pour
le faire on peut pas fabriquer en france
si on n'a pas un coût de l'emploi qui
est compétitif on peut pas fabriquer en
france si on n'investit pas pour
justement accompagner la formation
quand j'entends les gens dire vous fait
des mauvaises réformes mais faudrait
fabriqués chez nous c'est pas vrai c'est
un mensonge
c'est un mensonge on augmente le smic
alors c'est du blabla ça c'est quoi
c'est quoi le coup le coût de production
c'est quoi en fait c'est les salaires en
fait moi le seul coût du travail qu'on
arrive à vous faire croire que un
ouvrier coûte de l'argent parce que le
coût du travail ça veut dire que je
coûte de l'argent
depuis quand un ouvrier coût de l'argent
un patron moi je suis persuadé qu'il a
longtemps fait mais c'est pas décharger
les cotisations sociales c'est un
salaire lui qui fabrique ces
les seuls qui fabrique la richesse ce
sont les brader travail et à la richesse
qui pavoise a dit m il n'y a pas de coût
du travail le seul coût du travail que
je connais et qui malheureusement triste
c'est qu'il ya à peu près 500 entre 500
et 600 morts au travail par an ça c'est
des folk ou séoul paix que je connaisse
le coût du travail
il n'y a pas un nom un ouvrier qui coûte
de l'argent un patron c'est sont eux qui
enrichissent les patrons c'est quand
même incroyable d'entendre ça le coût du
travail le salaire c'est le coût du
travail
bah lennon et tu veux quoi tu veux plus
me payer en plus c'est non mais est
terrible ces mots qui sont mis cette
sémantique qui détruit totalement la
vraie valeur
l'ouvrier les bras des travailleurs ce
sont eux qui fabrique des richesses les
actionnaires se sont des nuisibles se
sont totalement des nuisibles une
aussière main rien dans les colonies
harry la terminologie utilisée en france
n'a rien à voir avec la terminologie qui
est utilisé par exemple aux états unis
moi je suis allée pareil pour les
general electric aux états unis parce
qu'on en fait un procès là bas à general
electric pour essayer de forcer cette
multinationale américaine à remplir ses
engagements par rapport à l'état
français
ils se sont engagés à créer 3000 emplois
l'état français mac on ne fait rien même
pire dissimule l'existence de cet
engagement pour ne surtout pas avoir à
dire quoi que ce soit de ce style à
l'égard de general electric et ce sont
les salariés qui se substitue à l'état
là pour le coup et vont faire un procès
à de général elektriks pour que les
américains crée de l'emploi en france
qui sont en train de faire exactement le
contraire
bon eh ben franchement quand vous avez
un état qui a une position aussi
extrémistes ils sont extrémistes dans le
domaine de l'idéologie libérale ils sont
vraiment enfin à la limite de ce qu'on
peut faire et que vous utilisez des
termes qui sont maintenant diffusées
même vous quand même vous vous présentez
grether les n'existe absolument pour y
enfermer le bel arrêt pour enfants
regardez mon nul
regardez moi je veux dire là dessus de
la guerre sémantique elle est
extrêmement importante pour comprendre
l'entourloupe dans laquelle on vit
qu'ils s'appellent le capitalisme alors
ça peut fonctionner à la papa et cetera
l'emmener quoi dans le néocapitalisme
vraiment c'est les actionnaires qui s'en
foutent plein les fouilles pour parler
trivialement mais coût du travail
effectivement c'est pas un coup charges
sociales c'est pas des charges
flexibilité du travail ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire virer les gens plus
facilement c'est tout après on en remet
ça avec un peu de formation mais
derrière tout ce qu'on nous cache c'est
la captation du profit on n'a jamais
autant été productif dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
où est passé l'argent voilà vous n'êtes
pas des saints argentaria c'est à dire
que là où on finançait une structure
sociale et ça revient sur le débat des
retraites
on a les moyens d'une solidarité
nationale même international on peut
faire la sécu on peut faire la retraite
on peut même faire quelque chose de
fantastique
seulement vous avez quelques races ayant
un livre qui est sorti avec ce titre là
qui capte la richesse qui capte le
profit qui sont actionnaires et au 21ème
siècle
je suis désolé il va falloir remettre la
lutte des classes sur la table et soit
vous êtes actionnaire que vous êtes
révolutionnaire et bien pas de choix
alors bien sûr qu'elle n'existe pas mais
mais on veut la voir mais les profits
d'hermès est l'une des pleins de cours
fait le mot là c'était en fait c'était
plus compliqué c'est la fête c'est guy
yotine qu'il a voulu dire lutte des
classes et elle va falloir remettre la
guerre non parce que c'est une lutte
politique
moi je pense pas que des politiques
basées sur les yachts ou la joue tous
les jours comme vous êtes ouvrir les
déclarer monsieur le sait la ville côté
vous avez votre patron rien c'est eux
qui debout du stade icahn a rappelé
arrêter la lutte des classes et finesse
que m contraction toujours les patrons
noyer ces choses et palaja nos solutions
vous allez dire ça si tout ça n'était
pas drôle qui sert d ce qui s'est passé
quand ça c'était faut pas généraliser
but de ces sétois tron qu'il est censé
les ouvriers qui sont et on arrête ça
c'est pas dans l'autre sens quand on
arrache la chemise du responsable
d'agencé le prix doit appeler cette
scène où on arrache la chemise du
responsable d'air france parce que il se
fout ouvertement de la gueule des gens
en caméra cachée y laisser quelques
rations oui tous et qu'on en fait il
faut les mettre dehors ça va vite ça
suffit là on a quelque chose de l'ordre
de la violence mais une violence cachée
c'est à dire que l'avion sans cravate
s'est jamais de la violence et quand
vous êtes à bout parce que vous savez
que vous [ __ ] à la porte que vous avez
rien derrière votre famille bien sous
manéo violent mais la violence en
cravate jamais les mondiaux avec jamais
quand vous avez un patron qui vient vous
voir et qui vous expliquent comme chez
continental par exemple hookaew chez ou
chez air france qui vous explique que
vous allez faire des efforts vous
baisser les salaires vous avez moins de
2 comment dire de repos on réduit tout
et que grâce à ça vous allait sauver
votre boîte et que c'est le même mais
qui vient trois ans après vous dire
qu'il va vous licencier quand même en
face de lui si vous avez juste envie lui
péter la gueule
et si c'est la violence elle est où la
violence est cerné si c'est possible
mais la gare routière les gens soient à
vis en matière aujourd'hui mobile oui on
peut travailler gratuitement sénat sur
sa récente blessure c'est la répartition
des richesses
les goodyear ils ont bataillé pendant
sept ans pour empêcher la fermeture de
leur usine mais surtout pour garder
leurs emplois et leurs salaires
et pendant qu'ils ont conservé leur
emploi et leur salaire est bien il
conservait une partie des richesses de
goodyear et que voulait faire goodyear a
voulait fermer cette usine licencier les
gens pour que les richesses qu'ils
étaient prises par les salariés
reviennent aux actionnaires cette
bataille là ça s'appelle la lutte des
classes et de tous les jours partout
voilà et ça se voit peut-être davantage
dans les grands groupes où vous avez des
organisations de salariés qui savent
organiser la résistance ça me met
partout même dans les petites
entreprises ya une bataille au quotidien
pour savoir où va la richesse bien sûr
que
les entreprises qui ne font plus de
richesse il y en a oui quand il ya des
bonnes raisons avaient déjà vu moi
franchement je vois les salariés qui
m'appellent pour engager des actions
judiciaires dans le cadre de ces
batailles tous les jours jamais n'est
jamais aucun salarié étant vraiment dans
une structure en faillite qui a vu son
patron voilà retrousser ses manches pour
essayer de relever jamais ils m'ont
appelé pour venir faire un procès dans
ce cas de figure
lorsqu'on m'appelle c'est parce que il y
a des richesses faramineuses et qu'on
les licenciés en même temps et que
veulent organiser une bataille qu'on
appelle la lutte des classes pour que
ces richards l'a aidé à continue à être
convertis en salaires en emplois et ne
soit pas tout d'un coup injectés dans
les comptes en banques qui sont déjà là
à craquer de quelques petits
actionnaires
voilà c'est ce que ces entreprises et ça
se passe ils ferment des usines jour
délocaliser elle délocalise aussi leurs
profits elle utilise les paradis fiscaux
pour ne pas payer l'impôt en france
donc vous avez une double arnaque celle
à la fois de faire croire que l'emploi
existent et que le derrière les
promesses d'emploi il y aura une
première très vrai ça c'est bon de les
assister
mais les vrais assistés s'est laissé
laisser des actionnaires ce sont les
plus gros assisté de la planète
ils nous font rien ils en gagnent ils
ont acquis à paris rêve et viril et la
vineuse goodyear fabrique a admis à qui
appartenaient les pneus goodyear
fabriqués sur le territoire picard à
amiens lorsque le pneu sortait de la
chaîne à qui il appartenait ce nom il
appartenait à une société
luxembourgeoise
voilà la société luxembourgeois c'est
très simple à comprendre apportait le
caoutchouc
mettez le caoutchouc voilà au début de
la chaîne et à la sortie de la chaîne le
caoutchouc ont été transformés en pneus
mais le pneu continuer à appartenir à la
société luxembourgeoise qui avait donné
la masse salariale et d'eau ensuite le
pneu il est vendu en france à la sortie
de cette usine il est vendu en france à
un client français mais qui fait la plus
value 1 la marge elle est réalisée par
qui par une société au luxembourg et
donc le profit et tu remarques pendant
que são luís sambo et mans j'avais 11 01
pauvres zhéros repères leur part c'est
sur le parler les fils ira européen vous
avez le luxembourg le pays bas
l'irlande l'abbaye de malte le portugal
d'une certaine façon il n'y a aucun plan
au niveau européen pour lutter contre
ces paradis fiscaux intra-européen
d'ailleurs on les traite pas de paradis
fiscaux et des partenaires commerciaux
nous on est tous ses voisins son départ
à ses fils ses normes
ils sont cinq paradis fiscaux sur les
cerveaux ils sont puissants et non en
tout cas également celles ci sont pas
ils sont pas ils sont passés ici
question avions sont là des questions et
des réactions tout cas nos
téléspectateurs on va les découvrir
et la question posée sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est l industrie française at
elle un avenir oui nous dit un
internaute à condition que le
gouvernement protège nos fleurons au
lieu de les vendre à tout va réaction
alexis poulain protéger les fleurons ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire d'être
protectionniste ça veut dire protection
oui mais pour marcher il faut il faut
avoir des il faut être capable de se
protéger
aujourd'hui on a quelqu'un à la tête de
l'état qui vend en lots l'industrie
française la france en général quand il
fait le rendez-vous de versailles c'est
pour dire investissez ya plein de trucs
à faire quand il fait la réforme des
retraites c'est pour ouvrir des nouveaux
marchés de la dette au fonds
internationaux on n'est même pas capable
de créer un fonds souverain français
parce qu'on pourrait on pourrait dire
écoutez on va créer un fonds
nationalisées ou chèques sont bien sûr
mais français les fonds de pension mais
non mais non pas un mais je ne sais pas
on pourrait on pour être bref est
souverain là dessus on pourrait dire
pourquoi pas il n'y a aucune politique
de défense des intérêts français
quand vous avez des glissements moi je
vois pas je vois pas où est cette
musique à l'international accord et
c'est absolument délirant pour le prix
de transfert bon je veux pas rentrer
trop dans les détails mais des prix de
transfert c'est vraiment l'état qui
acceptent de se faire escroquer le seul
pays au monde où tout cas dans le nom de
on va dire industrialisés et développés
qui acceptent les prix de transfert de
cette ampleur mais vraiment on se fait
rouler dans la farine
écrabouillé marcher dessus et ils disent
merci mais c'est absolument délirant et
disent merci
et ça c'est l'idéologie que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure vous avez aujourd'hui au
pouvoir des gens c'est vraiment le aux
derniers reliquats de l'ère thatcher
c'est les derniers ouvrages ils ont même
la porte le monde ya sa gêne même aux
états unis trump etc
ils ont complètement renoncé à cette
idée au viager c'est déjà des cavernes
ils seraient des hommes des cavernes
il continue à penser comme maintenant
mais cette école il faut casser cassez
cassez tout ce qui ressemble à une règle
de protection sociale casser tout ce qui
peut éventuellement se frayer un chemin
pour empêcher des multinationales
d'accomplir leurs désirs
c'est absolument incroyable et il ya
vraiment maintenant grand besoin que en
france ça soit énoncée et qu'on se
rebellent un peu quoi et efficacement
quand même que jouer mais il faut qu'on
se rebellent efficace à leurs autres
ça suppose que ce qu'on est en train de
me dire mythique moi oui bien sûr
question industrie française at elle un
avenir non pas dans le cadre de l'union
européenne qui encourage les
délocalisations et nous met en
concurrence avec d industrie plus
compétitive plus des industries dans
l'europe
en fait je comprends pas je comprends
pas l'intérêt de l'europe puisque les
usines les usines des trois-quarts de
france qui sont partis c'est dans des
pays européens alors que c'est quoi le
rock ça sert à quoi l'europe en fait je
comprends pas mais ce n'est même pas à
protéger les usines françaises la france
fait partie de l'europe
l'europe devrait protéger la france les
a réduits d'aidé à l'industrie
pourquoi c'est quoi la concurrence géré
par parler les plus grandes
multinationales et les ouvriers polonais
ils sont plutôt peu content de l'ordre
oui c'est mal et voilà c'est ça ça n'a
pas servi les intérêts de la france et
l'algérie a construit le fait de fait
sur whirlpool
il ya un effet de vases communicants
direct au détriment des des travailleurs
picard et au bénéfice des travailleurs
au japon là donc c'est de fait l'union
européenne elle l a fait deux tiers des
délocalisations industrielles françaises
sont partis vers l'union européenne
certes le 10 % la région alexis poulain
très courte pour terminer l'union
européenne part d'un principe solidaire
onglet en commun le charbon et l'acier
c'est plutôt bien justement parce qu'on
est dans un optique protectionnistes
dans les années 50 et puis arrive les
années 90 et là on est parti sur le
néolibéralisme et la compétition de tous
contre tous il travailleurs détachés il
faut quinze ans pour se rendre compte
que c'est une énorme bêtise
aujourd'hui on se rend compte mais c'est
pas possible il faut il faut bien sûr
défendre des champions nationaux et même
pour qu'on est incapable de faire des
champions européens c'est toujours là
sur la table
est ce parce que parce que le même
principe européen aujourd'hui tel qu'il
est à bruxelles
ils n'autorisent pas ça pire il combat
ça donc il faut complètement changé si
on veut avoir un avenir dans ce dans ce
monde oublié que derrière un fleuron
quand on emploie le mot fleuron se
seront moi la première chose à savoir si
c'est les travailleurs qui sont dedans
et du sable c'est pas un boeing c c ou à
airbus c'est les travailleurs qu'ils ont
fabriqués donc faut jamais oublier cette
petite dame qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
elle a fait partie de deux ça qui fait
partie du fleuron de
2 on est fiers de l'industrie 116 essaye
ce sont eux les curieux qui la mène et
c'est à eux qu'il faut penser quand on
achète au quotidien contre et il faut
les payer
on conserve ou les faire parler on a
largement dépassé le timing de cette
émission merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir débattu sur ce plateau ce soir
pollitt ma gueule la suite l'info restez
avec nous
[Musique]
ces sentiments que vous avez eue vous
aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement vrai besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes